bonjour à tous ce matin je vous retrouve
de la rédaction de tv 78 comme vous
voyez il est haut il n'y a pas encore
grand monde nous aujourd'hui on va
partir avec notre téléphone une petite
vos propre à deux caméras on va
participer à l'opération nettoyons la
planète avec des enfants du collège
alexandre dumas c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
sinon c'est tout ce que mes goûts douch
qui se recycle ses nanas d'accord et
tout le reste le reste est
donc là on va on vient de faire un petit
briefing avec tous les élèves et on est
parti pour la le ramassage on a vu qu'il
y avait des sacs spéciaux pour le
recyclage pour les chaussures recycle
pas un sac spécial pour les mégots
notamment qui met dix ans à se dégrader
le sac des mégots jetés des mégots
voilà ils sont pas sur un petit espace
je crois qu'il va être bien nettoyer je
trouvais un truc avec encore du café et
ayant copains il la trouvait même un
marteau dans les bouchons
et joindre remarqué que les gens jettent
à tout et n'importe quoi moi j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de plastique beaucoup de trucs
comme ça des bouteilles beaucoup de
cannes est un peu trop est beaucoup trop
de mégots là les mégots l'écrivain
trouve à perdre de vue regarder à chaque
fois on ne ramasse en plus on fait moins
on peut faire une collection faite pour
ça qu'il va être remplies avant la fin
envers la
minorité d'alcool mais c'est vraiment
que les gens ils sont sincères
la ccq là
on est avec n'a elle en a presque fini
notre un massage ça fait à peu près 45
minutes et de toute façon on ne peut pas
faire plus puisque les sacs sont
quasiment tous pleins
les gants vous allez surtout bien vous
laver les mains pour mémoire après je
vous redonne hamas avec isabelle et
bling professeur deux ps au collège et
organisatrice de cet événement du coup
moi avec mon groupe nous on a ramassé
pas mal de soucis de tête je peux
compter à peu près 15 à 20 kg avec mon
groupe donc isabelle comment ça s'est
passé pour les autres groupes déjà ce
matin et comment ça va se passer pour le
reste de l'opération alors les bains les
autres groupes là j'ai pas j'ai pas
leurs résultats j'ai vu revenir avec les
bras et charger des sacs pleins des
caddies de grandes barres de fer on n'a
eu qu'à le groupe ce matin à lutter quel
groupe tout à l'heure on puis quatre
groupes demain donc pour les résultats
ce sera demain donc moi je vous retrouve
en plateau directement pour faire un
petit débrief avec vous